joining us now is Tobias Elwood
conservative MP and former Defense
Minister now chairman of the defense
select committee Boris Johnson
thoughts this morning first of all
wow well I mean there's huge or was huge
undulation and love for Boris Johnson he
was quite phenomenal stepping onto the
you know political stage of the last few
years what he did in City Hall as mayor
of London what he did in 2019 but that
adulation now has turned to massive
frustration and indeed disappointment as
he deserts the political Battlefield
we're up against it we know that all
your discussions this morning has shown
that against labor and yet now we face
not one but three by-elections and
everybody's just astonished that he's
walking away in this way causing so much
damage in his wake
we were just starting to settle down
we're just starting to show focus with
the last couple years has been littered
with factionalism populism you know
Division and Richie sunac is just
starting to settle things down with a
measured more calm approach a statecraft
returning to number 10 and yet here we
are again having to deal with these
headlines not the tech Summit which uh
and what's going on in Ukraine which you
know I'd prefer to be focusing on so I
hope Russia's neck actually takes us as
an opportunity to First build a draw a
line under what Boris Johnson has done
he's now Departed the House of Commons
he won't be standing as as an MP uh well
I don't think any in any time soon I
mean how could any association
conservative Association accept him
after what he's now done given the
fights that we have uh to try and win
the next general election so let's move
forward let's recognize that uh Rishi
sunak has an opportunity to continue
with his message set out his stall and
then MP ease can absolutely buy into
that and I think the nation would
appreciate that and appreciate the
calmness that there is a line being
drawn
um you know uh on about Boris Johnson
just before we move on to other masses
um the vote will still go ahead we're
told on whether he should be suspended
even though you know he's already gone
will you vote in favor of him the
suspension well a lot of this discussed
in the last few days has all been about
the Privileges committee report it's
still embargoed it's not even out there
for the public to see MPS are likely to
look at it very very carefully indeed I
suspect many will not go against the
actual privileges committee
recommendations which bear in mind has
got a conservative majority on it I'll
look at it very carefully but I suspect
most people most MPS will be supporting
um the recommendations that the
committee made in other words that he be
suspended even though as I said he's
already gone
um what's going on in in Ukraine has the
counteroffensive now begun yes it has
but I mean I urge caution into assuming
that we're just gonna the Ukraine is
just gonna charge in and then the the
Russians would be dispersed and it will
be all over very very quickly what we're
seeing is a lot of shaping and probing
operation is taking place over only a
thousand kilometer front line they're
trying to weaken forces test them see
where the weaknesses actually are you've
actually got the main front of Ukrainian
capability still in reserves if you like
ready for that
um uh singular attack the Russians don't
know where it's going to be but we're
seeing chaos ensue between the Wagner
group and the Russian forces themselves
that the kakova dam explosion is an
illustration whether it was done
deliberately or by accident that they're
not in a good position that their Putin
didn't even have faith in be able to
holding that down so critical as a
bridge across from one side of the
Junipero to the other and it will
actually cause more damage to the
Russian forces and did the Crimea than
it will to the ukrainians as well so in
the next few days we should anticipate a
major attack in one part of the donvas
or another what more can the Brits do to
support Ukraine well we've done an
incredible job we've actually put
forward you know I think uh stressed the
political um appetite to increase that
support that mustn't dissipate we've got
the important vilness NATO Summit coming
up other countries need to meet the same
standards that we are providing so more
tanks f-16s long-range missiles they
don't need people they've mobilized
their entire adult population against
this motivation is something they have
as well what they need is more
sophisticated high-tech equipment and
follow Britain's lead in providing that
I'm sure you've seen Deborah Haynes
report this morning that military
personnel relying on food banks forced
to sleep in their offices as they can't
afford the fuel to drive home what
should the government doing about this
well we have uh I mean overall it's it's
always a difficult picture when we see
people relying on food banks but the
Armed Forces Covenant is something that
actually provides a national commitment
to look after veterans and service
Personnel given the unique circumstances
or the the work that they do for
protecting the country so I'm very
concerned about the reports that have
coming out what Abraham's reporting I'll
be discussing it with my committee to
see what we can do to highlight this and
place greater pressure on the government
to meet its common commitment when will
you speak to the committee well we're
actually on a visit today so we'll be
discussing it today but we have a couple
of sessions this week where we'll be
raising this and what are the options
well the options are you know we have to
place this to the government it's not
for us to then provide the policy we
scrutinize what the government is doing
to provide that critical support to
Veterans and those of the Armed Forces
but it's a very poor state of
circumstances isn't it when we see
people who have served who are serving
having to lean on food banks okay it's
always great to see thank you very much
indeed for joining us Mr Elwood thank
you